haha the Joe Rogan experience the the
virus thing just made me think I think I
was talking to my dad a lot about about
my grandfather and just brought it it
made it so real to me because I studied
World War two a lot this especially the
Holocaust and all that but like the the
fact that just learning about my
grandfather just made it so real to me
it kind of connected everything together
plus there's a book I recommend people
read is um by Albert Camus called the
plague that he wrote right after World
War two is I don't know if you know if
he is he's like an existentialist
philosopher existentialist believe that
you know you have to live like life is
absurd life is life is suffering and
there's no meaning to it all you just
have to live the moment and take take
each moment as it comes and live it to
the fullest kind of kind of idea so he
described his town that got overtaken by
the plague in the book the Blake and
that kind of similar to bubonic plague
basically similar characteristics and
writes about how everybody reacts in
different ways the main character is a
doctor who basically sees the the
absurdity of the suffering around him
that there's no meaning to it all that's
the thing about the virus like with the
Nazis and with Wars there's an enemy you
can kind of trace back and understand
what was happening I mean the virus it
just seems like it can't comes out of
nowhere you know and it breaks the spine
of the way we think of regular life like
some people try to cling on to regular
life as if nothing is happening which by
the way it's kind of like what a lot of
our society is doing right now we're not
yet we haven't really felt the pain yet
and and hopefully we won't but there's
this kind of dull the calm before the
storm kind of period and then some
people become like more religious they
start to search for the bigger meaning
of life outside of the material
possessions and then the doctor
represents the idea that no matter what
he he gives himself fully to his
to his craft of helping other human
beings and overall there's a story that
this idea that suffering is just part of
life and the only way there's a natural
temptation when there's cruelty and
suffering all around you to isolate
yourself and to uh to withdraw from life
because anything you do in life is going
to lead to suffering you know dating
like if you get married it's gonna lead
to suffering because eventually you're
going to lose the people you love so
there's a natural desire to withdraw but
in fact what he found the doctrine what
he saw around him is that love and
compassion like giving yourself fully to
the love of other human beings into his
community is the only way to deal with
that kind of suffering that's a to me
it's a really profound story about like
about love being the right response in a
time of crisis called crisis and the
crisis that hits everybody they you want
to kind of hide from it but it actually
were more suffering happens so it's a
it's a kind of profound book that I
recommend we got a that I recommend
people read most people have read like
in him in high school for this book
called the stranger but that one in
particular seems so connected to oh
sorry he wrote in as an allegory for
World War two so the plague in that case
is the Nazis mm-hmm that it just hits
out of nowhere and his book was really
popular I think in 1947 he wrote it
because you know as a kind of allegory
of World War two a way to talk about
these the virus that first infects the
rats and then affects the weaker humans
it affects everybody it was a connection
and an allegory in analogy to the Nazis
and so I saw the connection see now and
and the Nazis
of course the scale their world World
War 2 was much more intense and and and
finally just how like fragile this whole
damn thing is like that my grandfather
had probably single-digit percentage
chance of living you know like most
people died most soldiers died in the
especially in those early years of 1941
when the Nazis I think basically Stalin
was using Russian soldiers and just
human beings as human shields but yeah
just through bodies at the problem so
the fact that my dad my grandfather
survived seems crazy like and I do all
these things I'm here talking to you
wearing a stupid tie like all of that is
connected to like he somehow survived I
think all those look real ripple effects
me doing research you know I hope to
impact like billions people one day you
know those like a little ripple effects
like how fortunate I am to be part of
that I mean it just always seem to be
connected to me
[Applause]